on va commencer avec le premier titre il
chante vraiment battre le mans oui c'est
maxime gagny
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi
merci
quelle mère chanteur dit nous assure
l'auteur non mais une catastrophe
et toi cyril qu'est ce que tu deviens tu
te fais maria tas de gamins et toi
l'accès routier au chômage et une
catastrophe jeux sont issus pourtant
mais les paroles sont faussés côté marie
c'est dans il chante très bien mais on
n'entend pas d'accord marina pour moi
ils sont juste bons riffs sont justes
mais c'était une cc vous mettiez et vous
mettez combien circonvient sur dix sur
dix mois je mets comme 7 7 7
moi je me sens un peu un peu moins de 6
coups de fait quand on prie pour le
préféré je vous le dis voilà si vous
voulez une deuxième chanson d'une
personne vous avez ici le sait en haut
rhin c'est vous expliquera comment s'en
servir tout à l'heure merci bon allez
vous asseoir
on va accueillir maintenant benjamin
castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
asrar à ce rang vous venez simplement de
fermer ta gueule à faire leur fête
connais tu va chier avant tu dis que
c'était ça sera bon alors on la refait
il refait l'enquêté mais vraiment ras
sera way est en tout cas 27 cette
coiffure ou battre ça ça pour la
production
ozawa rival goldman mais ça veut dire à
quelle heure est aussi bien sur glane
quoi le la main porte quoi allez c'est
reparti elle est très importante pour
lui cette chanson il nous dira après
c'est beau
j'ai dit rinçage et paddy quasimodo yard
pas possible cela quelques semaines mais
rhodia
mavuba la tournette
l onac du lider astra sont allés chez
casino dont il s'est fait une bâche le
gagner comme à aller on va enchaîner y
reviendra tout à l'heure à aller on va
passer à agathe au cou agathe au cou
[Applaudissements]
mais est ce que tu as déjà vu une
chanteuse mon frère la part et paroles
elles sont parties il america partie à
l'école c'est bon je peux y aller bon en
plus vous écris il ya une barque avec
elle c'est qu'elle est persuadée que
c'est une grande chance si on m'avait
les perdrait-elle chambres d'enfants
alors tu vas dire et c'est très triste
et très premier degré sur le nord et on
lève cette casquette c'est ridicule non
mais vraiment merci
s comme tu es tu ressembles assez comme
ça m pokora sambo
et attend mais dense un peu fait quelque
chose sans rigoler la meuf en direct
sans déconner on allait comme à dire est
qu'elle en train de réciter une poésie
sur la tête de ma mère un monsieur d'un
public m'a fait comme ça un monsieur
d'un pays que vous avez fait du stop
pour fait il ya bien le gars le lien
croyait pas à une pancarte clermont
ferrand merci merci non mr mais danser
un peu fait un petit truc un peu sexy
c'est sous des lamas phalaris sans
déconner dire à un porte-manteau mon
frère est arrêtée du sûr ça nous est
venue et qui seul bavoux repartira
compagnie c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
alors là je ne répondrai pas répond plus
de rien
[Musique]
maman sur la tête de ma mère
un naufrage mais un naufrage en direct
quoi franchement non un peu pas pour moi
c'est un très beau jeu de scène merci
beaucoup
même si c'était au départ pas tout à
fait présent mais là j'ai vraiment bien
joué dit merde franchement non maigri
cardio à l'escalette je n'avais pas
envie de vous le dire mais franchement
sur sa prestation
ne nous mentons pas non franchement
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup mais c'est honteux marina moi
je n'ai 8 francs
alors oui oui sur 8 sur 10 moi j'aurais
mis 8 sur 100 igor et grichka sont très
gentil mari l'a dit la vérité ma chérie
je te prêter comme ma soeur non mais
franchement elle a une douce voix 26 ans
elle a douze fois les jo se sont
endormis jeu de mouvement son seul
défaut c'est d'être un des plus
régulières dans la tenue du micro c'est
le seul défaut est là franchement tu
mérite au moins pour moi huit noms 6 2
non si vos pages romain 7 6 7 1
merci allez on va accueillir maintenant
ah ouais ouais ouais on va accueillir
jean michel jean michel maire
go
[Rires]
[Musique]
avant de cimmérie s'ouvre sur la baule
c'est en colère au portel
puisque aucun dieu du ciel ne nous
viendra en aide
seigneur n'en fasse un lénine
réveille toi ils sont devenus fous ta
gueule toi
ça va m'enlever
halliche l'aise qu'au moins tu frissonne
quand tu vois les wagons de la
bureaucratie a tous voila rempli de tous
et non urgentes aux crises aux débats
palais
[Applaudissements]
le mec est un des poids l'année note
juste à opérer mais quand même s'ils
connaissent 6 marina à 8 une présence
scénique
il m'arrive une confiance et une percée
n'est pas les paroles il connaît pas
l'herbe
il a mis une perruque il aurait pu être
normal c'est bercy mais on va très bien
aller prochain d'artistes on va
accueillir
on va cueillir kelly au fiasco
kelly et là c'est la seule ma folie avec
r kelly a fait un bon allez c'est parti
à boxer bain
[Applaudissements]
si mal
je reste moi
mais bravo
g
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car je n'ai qu'une philosophie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu allais viser la lune l'abattoir nom
alors je vais vous dire y'a pas de
talent mais y'a les efforts non
messieurs
non non non non c'est pas mal la voix
spaemann week-end y aller mais
l'ambiance elle nous a fait le seul
karaoke tunisie leïla merci milk merci
micro combien il ya de la féminité du
mouvement et ça mérite quand même hein
un bouffer checke jusqu'à cette
paralysie
allez-y c'est le premier train part à
cette attention on va accueillir
maintenant alors je crois que c'est le
gars à qui les perruques bon le mieux
sur la tête de ma mère rien que ça te
tais je mets 10 août et pierre ménès qui
est avec nous qui va nous chanter
[Applaudissements]
mais du vieux pain sur son balcon
pour attirer des moineaux les pigeons
elle vit sa vie par procuration devant
son poste de télévision
elle a pendant la
l'aca hors du coup l'américain
excusez moi
c'est la musique
bonne et que je regardais je voudrais
que la musique du morceau forme était là
c'est beaucoup voilà c'est là que ça
commence
c
mais du vieux pain sur son balcon
pourra-t-il a trop tard amy jo elvis
habitat procure
you
télé
évidemment
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
avec le soleil sans vous sans angoisse
la journée ne pas repasser poussière y'a
que leur père repasse le critère centre
de
sur la tête de la mer des lacs à l'école
des fans c'était mon fils la base d'un
coin sig en présentiel donne à présent
qui est très intéressante et qui donne
beaucoup d'humour donc moi je vais quand
même aller je mets cette marina fois six
mois je pense qu'il n'a pas travaillé
d'accord mais pour ça il doit être un
petit mot puni donc il en a cinq
d'accord c'est bien géraldine mallet
c'est parti on enchaîne vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
faux
ah bon
coc
on s'est dit les choses
que
le tien
le temps que nous
sur le fond celui là
alors ya eu 13 une grande histoire un
effort ça va très bien et oui hé hé hé
voilà non c'est pas mal du tout et il ya
passe partout qui a demandé à reprendre
sa guitare tout cas il ya un effort et
puis il faut le saluer peut-être quelque
chose qui est en train de naître l'un
devant nous combien fait 7 2 2 non cette
cls proviennent des médiums alors je te
refais le manque de volume allemande
ouvre le bal valve à 10 ans montait à la
maison des boulettes 5 très bien
attention à l'est il reste deux
chanteurs bref trois chanteurs et pas
des moindres j'appelle valérie bénaïm
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais mais c'est pas ça du tout mais
faites là on n'a pas kellock cap et le
mcs a peur ouais patients 3 face à avec
you are the one formi formi formi
formidable you are my love very very
very véritable et je voudrais pouvoir un
jour enfin que le dire
[Musique]
et pas mal de l'aïe dans la rue
coeur de shakespeare mais tu décroches
ta mère allez vous asseoir pas mal on a
on a tout de suite
isabelle morini-bosc je ne sais pas ce
qui va nous chanter et d'ailleurs j'en
ai rien à [ __ ]
c'est parti alors il paraît que c'est
joe dassin après opération et ya pas de
musique j'ai chez moi une chanson
j'avais prévu l'équipage de jours puis
j'ai chanté j'ai marché
ouais attendez attendez vous deviez
chanter l'équipe à jojo oui mais déjà
écoutez moi ou vous êtes en quelle année
c'est intemporel joe dassin
oui on regrette un marine a maintenant
les vins dits oui merci voulait pas les
bancs d'écoliers dans le plus plu tout
d'abord ces chambres ensuite je parle
ici attention terre entière on s'est
aimés comme on se quitte tout simplement
sans penser à demain à deux mains qui
vient toujours un peu trop vite aux
adieux qui quelquefois se passe un peu
trop bien faire à donner avant avant que
vous avez fait violence bien su que le
hashtag grâce racheta que j'ai envie de
m'ouvrir les veines
oui j'en ai eu tout petit mais
maintenant mélange est charmant sortie à
la mer on était plus dans la version à
les y aller là bas
merci
c'est une chanson de gainsbourg sera
aussi pour mon rythme et ça donne ou la
mouche ferme les yeux tu verras ça
glissera mieux ouvre et ferme les yeux
surtout évitez éviter l'abus d'alcool
les ravages de l'alcool
merci bon pour l'inventivité et surtout
pour le secours d'une voix qui se passe
de la musique
ouais donc moi je met quand même site
marina alors moi je franchement je mets
mes neuf parce que pour son vin capella
c'est chaud ah oui c'est vrai ça qu'on
fait là-bas les gens qui soutenaient la
piste comme ça il y aura moins moi je m
comme d'habitude je vais mettre 5 pour
son courage non correctes c'est le
croire allez de suite benjamin castaldi
cession de sa deuxième appareil
attention à soi après les mecs se
raconter par l'émission
j'attends sourire de ces moments c'est
juste vous entendez à les paroles en
font preuve je voulais changer par le
croyais connaissez mieux les paroles que
jean jacques goldman qui avait créé la
chanson je n'ai pas entendu des paroles
[Applaudissements]
alors il remet à lens est muté à garder
tous les âges
j'ai tout sourire
auprès de moi
ouais nan men alors on va dire la
semaine à 1 c'est important cette
chanson bourg tournoi de san jose ont
préféré pourquoi pourquoi et bien parce
que quand ma grand mère est morte
5e mois avant que josh homme a vécu
cette sortie sara la p3 l'a donc moi je
les recopier sur la photo de ma grand
mère
et donc voilà ça d'abord il doit être
salué pour sa fidélité à préventive à sa
famille et puis ensuite il chante avec
son inconscient ouais ça c'est très bon
raymond l'a pas entendu intentions oui
je mets quand même huit allées marines à
l'histoire de la grand-mère était quand
même super bien placé exactement
voilà le nom des témoins c'est vrai
d'ailleurs qu'un break n'a pas du tout
qui fait mais comme l histoire la grand
mère elle veut pas je rappelle vous avez
toujours le buzzer menton d'accord oui
non et moi si tu veux je pense qu'il a
réussi quand même à 36 est une ode à
l'amour parce qu'on a senti qu'il décida
donc pour ça je lui mets au moins six
ah oui benaissa n'a pas eu ces notes
avaient considéré que vous avez eu une
note 6 mars à les attentions
le dernier candidat vous faut des
cheveux ont voté chez vous attention
c'est ma chanson préférée
oui oui c'est une de ses chansons
préférées match manquée de l'envoyer
valser bon merci
elle est à vous envoyez la musique trop
tôt voilà trop tôt quand je dirais
musique merde bavardons il va pas tarder
à nous faire chier les allées du coup là
non ça va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
el prat
[Applaudissements]
je vous entends les ennemis vous êtes
des vrais amis du jeune homme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
layton
on dit
l'étrange
les autres images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on se mouille
choix possible
[Musique]
sinon
[Applaudissements]
deux premières voies
mais
tout heureux
vous
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
là
il a derrière